dear fellow scholars this is two minute
papers with károly on IFA here two years
ago in 2016 we talked about a paper that
enabled us to sit and transfer our
gestures onto a virtual actor this work
went by the name face to face and
showcased a bunch of mesmerizing results
containing reenactments of famous
political figure heads it was quite
amazing but it is nothing compared to
this one and the reason for this is that
the original face to face paper only
transferred expressions but this new
work is capable of transferring head and
torso movements as well not only that
but mouth interiors also appear more
realistic and more gaze directions are
also supported you see in the comparison
here that the original method
disregarded many of these features and
how much more convincing this new one is
this extended technique opens up the
door to several really cool new
applications for instance consider this
self reenactment application this means
that you can reenact yourself now what
would that be useful for you may ask
well of course you can appear to be the
most professional person during a
virtual meeting even when sitting at
home in your undergarment or you can
quickly switch teams based on who is
winning the game avatar digitization is
also possible this basically means that
we can create a stylized version of our
likeness to be used in a video game
somewhat similar to the me emoji
presented in Apple's latest keynote with
the iPhone 10 and the entire process
takes place in real time without using
neural networks this is as good as it
gets what a time to be alive of course
like every other technique this also has
its own set of limitations for instance
illumination changes in the environment
are not always taken into account and
long haired subjects with extreme motion
may cause artifacts to appear in short
don't use these for rock concerts and
with this we are also one step closer to
full character reenactment for movies
video games and telepresence
applications this is still a new piece
of technology and may offer many more
applications that we haven't thought of
yet after all when the internet was
invented who thought that it could be
used to order pizza or transfer Bitcoin
or order pizza and pay with Bitcoin
anyway if you have some other
applications in mind let me know in the
comment section thanks for watching and
for your generous support and I'll see
you next time